Hola a todas, todos y todes
compañeras y compañeros,
os pido vuestro aval para presentarme a las primarias
como candidata de podemos
a las elecciones europeas.
Estamos dedicando
nuestros mejores esfuerzos para presentar
1 candidatura
a la altura de los retos que tenemos por delante,
hacer política para transformar España y Europa,
ser valientes y tener fuerza suficiente
para seguir impulsando
las transformaciones feministas,
por la Paz, de justicia social,
antifascistas y de cuidado del planeta,
aunque nos digan que es imposible
no conformarnos con parches,
sino IR a la raíz de los problemas
y demostrar que es posible
todo lo que ahora nos vuelven a decir
que no se puede hacer
o que vamos demasiado lejos o demasiado deprisa.
Os pido vuestra confianza
y os pido por eso
también vuestro aval para ser la candidata de podemos
a las elecciones europeas juntas,
con las razones y la esperanza intactas,
porque sabemos que a pesar del coste político
que nos quieren hacer pagar, sí se puede